we are indeed with the men of the hour
uh the leader in the open section
Fabiano caruana Fabi welcome back to the
show you're coming quite often uh to our
show that's the only reason he wins yes
oh it seems like you want to see us
we're doing a lot of shows together
recently that is true we see each other
quite often tell us about this game
actually first of all tell us about this
game the one between Lanier and elshon
because it finished in 20 minutes were
you completely shot was it actually 20
minutes yes maybe I saw this comments
when he when he castled after C4 because
this was played before this whole game
this was played in a high level game I
think it was like Grisha Duda
really really
I I don't see it like the way that
like after Bishop takes E4 this this
happens in some like online rapid game
okay yes probably rapid yeah yeah maybe
it's not not there but this was
definitely played I mean it's a trap
like you're supposed to play DC4 here
yes it's uh I played well you know we
prepared this line for the 2018 World
Championship so I played this quite a
lot with black and um
theories like Bishop C4 Castle rookie 1
Knight C6
D5 and Knight B8 I think I played like
this against Hare Krishna uh
but yeah I mean after once he played
Castle I'm like I know exactly what's
going to happen next so you were looking
at this game and you were already
pre-facing what's going to happen I I
didn't want to look
it's like it's like watching a car crash
in slow motion when when he plays Castle
and and you know exactly that he missed
it's a bit of a surprise that Bishop
before but I mean if you play this
opening you should know the basic tricks
about it and I think this was uh the
caveat he played perhaps for the first
time this opening uh now let's talk
about your why against I understand it's
a great opening the petrol but why
against linear an expert in the
background linear is like the biggest
expert in the world on the petrol it's
even if you don't lose in 10 moves it's
still a strange choice but okay yeah
it's uh accidents happen difficult game
indeed and you started with this
intriguing Queen to C2 followed by E4 as
well and it seemed like you surprised
your opponent early on how did you come
up with this idea well I saw that Alex
played this earlier in the tournament
DC4 so I thought maybe he prepared the
slot and specifically this line for the
tournament and I remembered that uh When
I Was preparing this opening for black
in 2020 for the candidates that this E4
line was very dangerous and later on
Perugia played it against me and it was
a very dangerous position I thought so I
thought okay this will be an interesting
try
um it was interesting because he
actually approached the position the
same way I did against Perugia yes well
like Bishop D3 A5 is
is probably the best move to get Knight
A6 quickly and a mess begins uh but he
played A6 and I was a bit surprised I
didn't expect that he would go for okay
we transpose later
um
to my game against Perugia like after
Rook D1 H6 I think we transposed
yes yeah so we got a different move
order I couldn't remember exactly how
but I remembered that he played H3 here
with the idea of Bishop E3 yes and this
was like an online game during the
pandemic and uh and I remember that this
this plan of Queen E2 to bring the queen
later to G4 was the most dangerous way
so you've analyzed that game against
fury like two years ago
um so I I kind of remembered some of the
ideas but I definitely messed it up very
quickly like I I think this 91 was
probably good
uh Queen B6 is very natural yeah I
wasn't sure Queen G4 Bishop P3 first but
let's say queen G4 G6 and yeah here I
was hesitating like Bishop B3 I was
worried that he'll get an IV Aiden and I
didn't want to allow this Knight B8 and
ic6 but maybe the Knight ends up being
very poorly placed there which is what I
realized later but the position was like
a bit of a mystery to me I was trying to
understand it he was playing very
quickly and I started to feel under
pressure and I don't really understand
the position well enough and uh
and so I wanted to stop his uh his IBA
that's why I played Bishop D2
I was thinking he would play A5 and I
would play uh and the Ada if he goes
Knight to B8 yeah here those Bishop
so B4 A5 was very natural and I was
thinking at least now his his Knight
can't get to B8 to deep to B4 but then I
realized that I don't really have an
easy way to continue to play like his
King is stuck in the center yeah but
eventually it might get to the King's
Island
yeah I wasn't too happy with with how it
turned out
so then we got I mean I think it was
about equal always I was a bit more
happy with my position than than his
would say at this point
how would you assess the position at
this point I was happy here but still I
was low on time and uh not exactly sure
so I played a bit
probably a bit um
too slowly and not concretely enough and
you could even say like a little bit um
possibly but still there are a lot of
things happening around the king side
you have ideas of Queen to F3 put a lot
of pressure on F7 and then this moment
came you took Queen to E2 yeah I mean
it's just very very silly because it was
a normalish game
complicated position I thought we both
played normally maybe not great but
normally and then just I
just absurd blunder I didn't understand
even what the point was and he taught
for like 13 minutes at this point what
was your reaction when you saw him
touching the king and going for King to
dream I hadn't even considered this move
in advance because it looks terrible you
you lose the loose and I don't have six
and then like within a second I saw that
you can take in flavor K5 I was thinking
one two options of his were one was this
Rook C3 it's very strange Queen E5 Queen
B8
and I was going to play Rook C3 because
if I take on E6 surprisingly I think
it's a mistake King F7 Knight G5 King G7
and then games are probably a draw but I
have Rook C3 BC
um Queen E3
and like let's say he has no easy way to
defend this Pawn let's say queen B3 or
K5 once my Rook gets in the game the
attack is tremendous so uh so this I was
happy with but I thought maybe after
Queen 294
after uh I thought I would be better but
and then he has Rook C3 in that this is
a crucial idea
and here I was looking at Queen E5 King
I wasn't sure where let's say yeah take
take and Rook A5
uh C2 Rook C5
yeah Rook Sierra I mean it's it's
holding on Holding On by
only this detail
yeah so here I lose here I lose because
the pawn yeah so that's why his King
goes to H7 not G8 because otherwise with
the King on G8 there's it's a check that
makes sense so here if you go King to
G80 yeah here same line
or maybe he has
there's no more but he has worked here
instead of
yeah okay
uh anyway black is the one who has to
calculate this to a draw so
I wasn't enormously worried but King
James just uh
very very mistake Fabiano uh first of
all congratulations uh you are winning
game after game but also your
competitors are coming from behind
especially Ray Robson what is your take
on Rey's result
oh I think he played a great game today
I mean I I didn't check the game but uh
it looked like he had a very strong
initiative from the opening I thought
Wesley played this very risky line
it seemed like Ray knew it quite well
and uh
I don't know if he was like always much
better but it looked like Wesley was
under pressure so so yeah Ray is playing
very well um I don't know who else is uh
nobody else is on plus two right no
Darius is on plus one but
is
uh and a wonder is losing to Jeffrey
right so Jeffrey goes on plus one is
that correct I wonder uh made the draw
against Jeffrey
Oh I thought he would um
plus one I think everybody is on plus
one yeah plus three yeah it's still a
long way to go but the last few days
have been good guys and indeed Fabby
just keep it up it's a pleasure watching
you play in great form and uh right now
you're on a roll so do enjoy yourself uh
I was actually wondering that of Fabiano
has this great score we remember we were
discussing that he has this fantastic
score against Alexander and is it
helping I mean is it helpful when you
know that your opponent doing really
badly with you I mean have you thought
about it I think it puts a lot of
pressure on on the other guy who doesn't
have a good score so it does get in your
head if you're consistently playing
poorly against someone uh so yeah
against Alex um
I've had a really good score the last
few years
we've only really played in the US
Championship but I've won every game so
maybe maybe that also contributed to
when he sort of feel Under Pressure then
it put him under a bit more
psychological pressure
yeah exactly and I thought also we were
discussing today about the different
approaches are you concentrated on your
game only and try not to really check
the games of the others or you really
like to walk around and check what's
going on no I check all the games I mean
today was impossible not to you know but
it looked like I mean it was a very
bloody day wasn't it yes yes Hans lost
it seemed like he got a very bad
position from the opening
uh Wesley losing is a really big result
yeah five decides of games I think so
far yes well I guess I guess Sam against
Sam will be a draw foreign
[Music]
so they're both playing solidly I guess
they're uh
they're playing decently 50 right isn't
it
plus one yes so he's having pretty good
tournament yeah yeah okay full control
over the old boards it seems like yes
thank you the Curious mind and again
very very well done I do keep up the
good work and let's take a look at the
results